Pro Football Hall of Famer who has been
there and done that playing it and
broadcasting it is Dan Fouts back here
on the show how are you Dan I'm good I
just listed love listening to it was
great hearing it the first time and
seeing it but yeah I am was all over it
as he always this as you know well you
were to you know I mean it in and you
did the you know you've you've been
there done that just let it all breathe
and then you got in there and told us
what you saw what happened I mean did
you see that unfolding at all Dan Fouts
periods were perfect and they were
backwards which is yes and obviously and
normally what we see in those cases
where you know after the second lateral
the next one hits the ground or hits an
offensive lineman and the game's over
and but in this case it just was
perfectly executed they got it to the
right guy I mean Kenyan Drake is the
fastest guy on the offense and so once
he got it it just looked like the
Patriots were running in slow motion and
then oh you know that's weird things
happen in Miami and that field was kind
of mushy and everything but it certainly
wasn't mushy for Kenyan Drake yeah and
where do you stand on the subject of
Gronk had no business being out there
yeah I don't think he should have been
out there because there's no way
Tannehill could have reached the end
zone with the pass you take out you know
I think it was Devin McCourty who's one
of their best tacklers in space and you
know Gronk was out there for one reason
is to knock a pass down not to make a
tackle well it's the longest pass play
or any play to end to get to them in the
Super Bowl era with no time left I mean
that's that's never happened before so I
will ask you this what's prior to this
what was the greatest most shocking
thing you had seen to end a game on the
field playing or or broadcasting Dan you
know Kansas City against Dallas I think
it was last year hit Tyreke Hill and I
think was at the end of the first half
and they executed you know that play
like it was a punt return and he got
into the end zone of course you know you
can always go back to the Miami charger
playoff game when the Dolphins ran the
hook-and-ladder
at the end of the first half which was
perfectly executed to get them in the
end zone
but this one it was just unimaginable
really that you could go that far with
just two laterals so you're yeah I guess
you're speaking from experience when
you're saying strange things happen in
Miami well they have I know that and
especially to the Patriots I mean when's
the last time you saw atomic Tom Brady
make a mental error at the end of the
first half and taking that sack without
any timeouts to kill the clock after it
so that's just plain weird yeah I know
and then Brandon Bolden of all people
scored not once but twice first two
touchdown game for him prior to all that
happening so how much do you take into
this knowing strange things happened
about the Patriots viability moving
forward down spouts well first of all I
think you got to give Adam GaSe a lot of
credit for you know putting Bolden in
there and because he hadn't cared that
one time all year is a special teams guy
but he's an expatriate so you know that
he's going to have a little extra juice
there and the Patriots did not Scout him
obviously but going forward you know
they're still going to win their
division which is what they do every
year for the last ten years or so so
it's interesting where they'll place
though with the playoffs coming up
obviously this game on Thursday night
with the charges and Chiefs is as big as
it gets and we'll have a you know a
large determination on not only of those
two teams futures but the rest of the
AFC and obviously the Dolphins I mean
what a huge W that is I mean they could
be sitting there at 6 & 7 with the
Broncos or where they are which is in
the seven seed now at seven and six do
you look at that team and think that's a
playoff team well they've got a great
boost today with the Vikings firing John
Dee filippo I in and I will be in
Minneapolis on Sunday for that game so
we're anxious to step into that bit of
drama and see just how much the Dolphins
can take advantage of that chaotic
situation in Minnesota okay so then you
led me to my next class
I had no idea you and I am recalling
that game so this is perfect then I'm
sure you were watching Monday Night
Football getting ready for that
broadcast what gives
I'll just throw that out there is it is
this the right manoeuvre to fire the
offensive coordinator with three weeks
to go based on what you're seeing from
this offense Dan
well let's go back a couple of years
when Norv Turner left and why did he
leave I mean obviously there's some
friction between the head coach and his
coordinators and it's shocking that with
the talent that they have with the
running backs and the wide receivers and
the tight end obviously it's an
offensive line issue that they can't
give Cousins enough time to find all
this talent and there's some you know
discord there as to how you want to take
advantage of it well I mean how much do
you lay at the feet of cousins then I
mean obviously his contract is something
that was talked about throughout the
broadcast and that's what all fans are
focusing on right now as well as the
fact that he just doesn't perform very
well on the road on under the lights
under teams that have a better record
than the one that he's playing again of
playing for so how much do you lay at
his feet here Dan well I I think
obviously any quarterback is going to
have to take as much criticism as
possible because he's the last guy with
the ball in his hand when he's throwing
it or handing it off so he's going to
you know have to look at his record as
you I pointed out rich but also he's
just calling and running the plays that
are called so there's plenty of blame to
go around you can't follow the
quarterback as Michigan 84 million
dollars though you can't fire the
coordinator apparently so how I look
what I said at the top of the broadcast
and because that firing happened
literally as we were coming on the air
you can't say that that that this change
is not gonna work when the Browns put in
Freddie kitchens as soon as they made a
change in the middle of the season and
they look like a completely different
offense so I'm wondering what you think
of the possibility that things could
turn around for the Vikings with the
three games to go here
well you know obviously it can turn
around I just think that with the
expectations coming into the season it
got in not living up to them kind of
like the Eagles it's a totally different
situation and the Browns I mean the
Browns are are rolling right now
you know Mayfield is having the type of
year that a lot of people in Cleveland
we're hoping that he would have a
totally different situation though I
think in Minneapolis yeah I mean iron
came on the show the other day Dan and
told us a story that really knocked us
off our feet to be honest with you that
when you and he were in the broadcast
meeting prior to what turned out to be
Hugh Jackson's finale you asked him you
know how come you're not running any
more place from Oklahoma or running
Oklahoma place to make me feel
comfortable I'll get some paraphrasing
the question and he said the answer was
I agree and I said well yeah I kind of
followed up a couple of times I said
well why not come on give me something
there but obviously there was some
disagreement with Todd Haley and and hew
I mean hew used to be a play caller
that's how he made his chops but for him
not to have an answer I think that's why
he's no longer employed yeah I mean
because the hike the HC should have the
final say clearly that that's the case
in Minnesota right now one would think
well that's why the word head is there
in front of coats right that's one way
to put it Dan Fouts that certainly is
one way to put it what do you think
right now of Philip Rivers
he's breaking records that you used to
hold Dan he's just a a dynamite all-time
great player what do you think of when
you see Philip Rivers I really enjoy
watching him play because he plays with
a passion he plays with toughness he
plays with smarts and I like the funky
throwing motion because it's compact and
it's accurate all the things about the
rivers I admire greatly I'm going
turn though coming Thursday night if he
doesn't have Eckler and if he doesn't
have Melvin Gordon how will they be able
to take on the Chiefs and that offense
of mahomes the biggest thing the win
you've got two rookie running backs for
that game sure they're going to run the
ball and they're going to be able to
make yardage but are they going to be
able to pass protect and that's where
rookies have the biggest problem and
with a defensive coordinator like Bob
Sutton with edge rushers and D Ford and
Justin Houston that's where the chips
have got to come that's where the double
teams have got to come and that's where
the blitz pickup from these two rookie
running backs has got to be spot-on I'm
concerned about that for the charges
what do you think Don Coryell would
think of the current state of offense in
the National Football League Dan because
we're talking about Phillip you're
talking about it's kind of a dying breed
where there's no run pass option there's
no threat of a run there's none of that
stuff there's no movement from just a
quarterback position that you're seeing
from all these young kids what do you
think your old coach would have thought
about the current state obviously he
would love it absolutely because it
would be confirmation to his philosophy
that you can move the ball you can win
games throw in the ball and so I was
fortunate enough to have nine great
years with him I believe he deserves to
be in the Hall of Fame because of his
contribution to the National Football
League on both sides of the ball because
defense has had to figure out a way to
stop the high-powered passing games and
and they've done that pretty much it's
interesting to see how well defenses are
playing late in the season now isn't it
I mean last night's game and what the
Bears did to the Rams it's it really
makes this time of year that much more
unpredictable so Dan I want to hit you
up before I let you go on Ben
Roethlisberger from from Sunday I'm sure
you were making your way out of the
hardrock after that shocking finish and
Roethlisberger as we all know suffered a
rib injury today he said that part of
the reason why there was confusion of
him coming back is because the x-ray
machine in Oakland
wasn't was old and they couldn't really
tell much from the actual machine in
Oakland is a Polaroid camera is it the
same one they used with you Dan from
back in the day it branda
are you serious by the way thing is back
in the 60s in that Stadium it's
ridiculous he said it led to part of the
the the I want to use a word issue but
the the lack of clarity on his injury
led to maybe him standing around and not
getting back into the game this was him
not don't give me the one with the the
x-ray give me the other one I want to
play the soundbite from you before you
Dan from Big Ben's radio show today and
just ask you your thoughts on him
talking about why he didn't come back
immediately into the game if I take the
field am I gonna make our team worse you
want to play unless you think you're
gonna hurt your team right you don't
just go out there just to be out there
so at this point we didn't know if I was
gonna get on the field or not but I
wanted to be out there and Kevin kind of
made the comment like you know it's not
our defense hold of Josh could get this
thing done but you know let's get out
there and I said I agree so we got back
out on the field and they're in the
middle of a drive we were and so I was
just out there kind of trying to get
loose keep it keep my legs loose and
really just being out there in an
emergency situation or to be there for
Josh to help support him and answer
questions for him and you know that's
kind of was the approach we took when we
came back that's the reason we came back
onto the field Dan Fouts what do you
think well that's his explanation and
obviously didn't have clarity on the
injury and felt that that was the best
decision I'm not sure who all led to
that decision that's how much input
Tomlin had and the doctors so it's it's
hard to really second-guess without
having full amount of information on the
situation well I guess I'm not asking to
second yeah it just strikes me as odd I
mean how many times did you were you
held out of a game and and you didn't
like want to get back in it just seems
strange this just doesn't it just seems
to be something missing
from the actual explanation here well I
can only ask answer for myself and the
answer would be never I always wanted to
play if I could you know hobble back
five yards I could throw the ball and
that would be it but the key part there
is he didn't want to hurt the team by
not being able to throw I guess and and
not being as accurate as he wanted to I
think that's what I would focus on is
that that said one of the first things
he said that would I be a negative if I
went out and played instead of a
positive Dan appreciate the time as
always
we'll chat down the road have a great
time I uni on were nailed it that was
really exhilarating to watch and I look
forward to your call the rest of the
year
thanks rich as always you bet right back
at you that's Pro Football Hall of Famer
Dan Fouts the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience